because you know what two years ago
Casey Woods brought the drama during
Monday's episode of Bachelor in Paradise
fainting after stirring up some conflict
on the beach
[Music]
I think it's going to be crazy this year
I mean it's always a little bonkers but
I know this season is going to be uh
heightened because we've got a lot more
people coming in and a lot of twists
that we haven't tried in the past now
Casey says he hasn't walked since that
moment went down more than four months
ago it honestly happened in a matter of
seconds I woke up on the ground I opened
my eyes I don't realize that my ankle is
just destroyed I actually tried to get
up and that's when I say oh my God are
you good are you good what what
my God the reality star made the
Revelation on The Bachelor Happy Hour
podcast
explaining that when he saw his ankle it
looked like someone had wedged a
football into it Casey says he was
rushed to a hospital in Mexico where
they put his ankle back in place then
after he went back home a doctor
determined he had three different broken
bones I had three weeks before I could
even get surgery because the swelling
was so bad I spent just about a little
over a month 23 hours a day in bed leg
up couldn't do anything Casey says that
he recently went to the doctor and was
expecting to get news that he could
start walking with a cane but instead he
learned one of his bones shifted a
little bit so he'll need another surgery
so for now he's still in a cast and
using a knee scooter to get around
is the accessory of the summer now
scooting into fall everybody's loving it
quite an unexpected affected turn of
events and just really sad but at the
same time you know thank God I didn't
hit my head on anything you know when it
comes to fainting it just it's just
completely you know you don't know
what's gonna happen Casey's injury came
after he told Brittany that Peter had
been saying some not so nice things
about her and got overwhelmed by the
drama that ensued
hey we should definitely talk tonight
[Music]
but Casey says he 100 stands behind the
choice to let Brittany know that
somebody was slandering her claiming he
told her because she deserved to know
not because he wanted to score her Rose
I think she absolutely deserves a right
to defend herself I also 100 knew that I
was not getting a rose from Brittany and
that's where it gets a little tricky
because
the night when I heard that from Peter I
immediately went to go tell Brittany so
she could deal with it and she was
making out with Andrew so I'm like there
wasn't a lot of like daylight in terms
of what was going on
[Music]